what was one day until the Women's World
Cup just one day anticipation is
building with 24 goals so far Team USA
has already set a record and along the
way it's earned admiration and some
criticism Roxana Saberi is in Lyon
France where the game between the
reigning world champions and the
relative newcomers will kick off
good morning Roxana good morning tarika
while Team USA had to defeat six teams
to get here now only the Netherlands
stands in the way of another trophy
nearly 60,000 people are expected to
watch the showdown here tomorrow many of
them dressed in red white and blue from
the streets to the stadiums tens of
thousands of American fans have cheered
their way across France to see Team USA
play and win
Kelly Rosenfeld is from Cincinnati
soccer and I think it's more interesting
than watching them many of these fans
believe the Stars and Stripes will make
soccer history by taking home a fourth
trophy if we can retain that trophy it's
it's gonna be a big thing for soccer in
the US but first the US has to defeat
one more team the Netherlands this is
only their second time at the tournament
but US defender Kelly O'Hara says she's
taking them seriously do you think you
guys might be under estimating the
Netherlands I don't think we
underestimate anybody as the u.s. warms
up for its final game here its players
are juggling questions on the sidelines
about if their goal celebrations have
been over-the-top I don't think we'll be
deterred by a couple of naysayers and
about if they'll visit the White House
if they win co-captain Alex Morgan is
one of at least three players who have
said they will not well that decision be
made as a team or as individuals I can't
say 100% but this team is very close
we've always made decisions together
the team's candor on controversial
topics is one reason they've made
headlines in the US and abroad says
grant wall a senior writer with Sports
Illustrated used to be they have
opinions and they're not afraid to share
those opinions and I think that's part
of their appeal and so is their talent
on the field of course if the u.s. wins
here tomorrow it will join Germany as
the only teams to win this tournament
twice in a row Jeff okay Roxanna thank
you very much yeah I know when you
covered this four years ago right when
they was on the road with them for
almost a month
they won 5-2 Carli Lloyd as you may
recall that the hat-trick and scored
three goals love to see her get some
more playing time but yes go Team USA so
the Netherlands is ranked 8th in the
world but Team USA has already beaten
England which was ranked third and
France which is ranked fourth so keep it
going we'll see